what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome
to morning coffee thoughts before I
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring the notification Bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos
today I want to talk about why it's
selfish to be a whale
yes yes ma'am yes sir now before I start
I wanna I wanna talk about a story
that's a little bit more near and dear
to my heart
my mother
now I don't always talk about my mom on
the channel but I'll tell you this my
mom was a whale at one point
yes yes ma'am yes sir she was
and my mom she was pretty dang fat when
I was younger
like basically she had seven kids and
she just said she gained 10 pounds with
you with each kid before you know it's
70 pounds my mom's wailing it and
my mom said that
um
she wanted to lose weight for my father
and when one day he had a trip to India
and he came back and she was like 30 40
pounds heavier
mine are not heavier lighter she was
lighter my dad was a happy man
but let me tell you the repercussions of
my mom being a bigger woman
when my mother was
um
because I think she was big till I was
like maybe 10 roughly maybe a little
yeah she had my last sister when I was
when I was 10. I think she lost the
weight a little something like eight to
ten but the problem was before that
because my mom had a bad sugar habit
then all of us got a bad sugar habit
and it's especially prevalent
and my oldest siblings we all love sugar
we can just eat sugar all day why my mom
used to feed me Pop-Tarts and so my
mom's bad habit
transferred to me
and now I had a bad habit that I still
fight with two I still fight with
to this like to this day I still have
that habit
and therefore my mom not killing that
habit transferred onto her children and
now it's her children's problem now I'm
old enough that it's my own fault now
Okay so
I will take accountability for that but
that's why it's selfish for you to be
fat
because ultimately you're going to pass
on those habits to your kids
and ultimately now your kids have to
suffer and deal with a battle that they
shouldn't have to deal with
so on top of that
you're going to have health issues
and if you've made it to 35
I'll give you 35 with zero health issues
from being obese
you're a lucky person but at some point
it's going to catch up to you and you're
going to have health issues and
you know what's going to happen who's
gonna have to take care of you
your husband your wife your parents and
why is that their problem why
on top of that when you walk anywhere or
go anywhere you know especially like now
we have the airport incidents where
you're just trying like I I flew in a
plane the other day and I'm just living
my life and these two fat people sit
next to me now I have to suffer
with your blubber on top of me why why
is that
and let's not talk about the Health Care
system
do you owe anything to your community do
you owe anything to your country
even if your health care is free the
whole Community has to pay for it all of
society so all these obesity problems
now the doctors have to see like the
doctors are meant to be solving real
problems not telling you to eat less
Diane
Rebecca
Jordan
yeah so
that's what the doctors are there for so
now the doctors have to deal with your
problems your kids now have the same
problems you have
everybody's gotta look at you
all right you gotta walk around in life
and everybody has to look at you
now
you could say I'm harsh and maybe I am
harsh but I'd like to say I struggle
with my weight all the time
and I know there's people that it's
going to be a constant battle for the
rest of their lives and I'm here to have
this conversation I would like to invite
all of the bigger women to come on the
show if you're in London because we want
we need to have a conversation about
body positivity
we cannot keep living in delusion that
fat is good we cannot keep calling me
guys even me I need to lose 15 20 pounds
and I need you guys to stop simping
and saying that I do not in fact need to
lose 15 to 20 pounds because all you're
doing
all you're doing is you're simping
and
oh yeah you can come up oh is he here
yeah
is he here blessing I think he's here
but but
he's here okay I'm gonna finish my
coffee talk
but my whole point is guys we can't as
women we can't keep living in delusion
the men don't deserve this they don't
deserve fat wise now is being fat the
same for a man and a woman no can we
stop pretending it is now I'm not saying
to stay fat fellas you need to lose
weight too nobody should be fat we all
should have the goal to lose weight and
be healthier but women are supposed to
be the beauty in a society we're
supposed to be the pretty ones to look
at it's not supposed to be the men but
now we have a society where the men are
thinner than us guys that's not
acceptable it's really not we need to
whatever your man weighs you should
weigh less than him
okay this shouldn't be controversial all
right you know I know we got a couple
tall
you know women I'm trying to say
less women in here and maybe you're
taller than your guy okay I'll give you
an exception
but not really you still should weigh
less than your guy all right myself
included all right
so guys
if you want to lose weight
we're gonna be doing a health Journey
here at just pearly things you know
we've been running up 21 flights of
stairs I have a vlog you know coming out
that I've been asking to come out for a
long time but I don't you know it'll
come out eventually I guess but but
foreign
but we all need to get into better shape
and we have to first admit there's a
problem